that's not my color they're brown no
they don't
carry right no I'm gonna stay great I
think that's like the pink lemonade no
mine's red is it orange this is
strawberry yes God's Auburn this is what
my face
[Music]
mmm Oh Larry I think it's tropical and I
think it's blueberry oh is this the blue
raspberry I knew it was one of my
favorite one
this is great girl
you can't just start yelling that's
great oh you know what no this is green
apple no oz berry I think it's just like
blueberry cherry are you some green
apple oh no wait it's Jerry Jerry
[Music]
I don't wanna go temple it's made up oh
baby it's gonna wait this is green apple
nice high five
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was bad at that I've expected much
more from me I feel like we should have
had it palate cleanser I to each one the
first when I got down but I think mixing
the flavors a little together kind of
like ruin my chances I think with candy
specifically even though the colors are
nonsense - what that flavor matches up
to in real life I think seeing that like
equates to the dictate candy flavored
candy version of like orange for me like
all the flavors when I first take a bite
it's it just tastes like sugar and then
like the flavor kicks in I guess most of
them wrong you plug them up M&Ms